hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and ever since we
got that massive twist about luffy's
devil fruit everyone's been speculating
about its true nature and origins we've
especially been wondering why this one
fruit seems to contain so many different
properties from rubber and fire to
lightning manipulation and shape
shifting well i'm here to tell you that
luffy may have already consumed multiple
devil fruits without even realizing it
and this is the true secret of the nika
devil fruit it wasn't always the nika
fruit because it actually started out as
something completely different before we
get into it quick thank you to bloodline
heroes of lithus for sponsoring this
video bloodline is a card based fantasy
rpg with 3d realistic graphics that
allows you to not only collect champions
and build your own kingdom but also to
create the legendary heirs of your royal
houses by combining the forces of
various bloodlines including orcs
lichens demons and dragonborn to create
overpowered offspring you can basically
ship your favorite champions with each
other to create new champions with the
best features of both bloodlines sit
back and enjoy the beautiful 3d
realistic graphics with easy controls on
a vertical screen customize your
champions and raise heirs to the throne
and obtain the best next generation
hybrid heirs for example you can get
this epic half dragonborn half demigod
air for free i think that the dragonborn
the lycanus and the demigods look
especially cool but every bloodline has
its own unique advantages just level up
to unlock more companions for free and
the higher intimacy your companions have
the more powerful the offspring will be
bloodline is free to play on both
android and ios so download the game
right now by clicking my link in the
description or by scanning the qr code
on screen use my promo code
bldhol1 to obtain one champion token 100
000 gold and 100 diamonds right now
finally this video will contain one
piece manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned okay
so once it was revealed that luffy's
gomugamunomi was not just a paramecia
devil fruit that has the properties of
rubber but rather a mythical zone devil
fruit known as the hitohitomi model nika
everyone started thinking back to all
the times that luffy's devil fruit
demonstrated properties that went beyond
just rubber even before awakening his
devil fruit for the first time in 800
years some of luffy's attacks like red
hawk and red rock clearly had the
properties of fire which isn't really
related to rubber luffy also exhibited
unusually high levels of resistance to
fire and that goes all the way back to
little garden you'll recall that back
then luffy was able to withstand being
extremely close to a massive fire while
trying to rescue his friends from mr 3's
wax luffy doesn't even complain about
the heat of the fire even though mr 3
who is right there next to luffy is
screaming in pain because the fire is so
hot and then he sprints away from the
flame as quickly as possible so despite
the fact that mr three is literally a
candle man who produces flames from his
hair while using his devil fruit luffy
still seemed to have way greater
resistance to fire than he did
then we have other details like luffy
being able to recover very quickly after
being frozen solid by aokiji and then
there's also the incident from chapter
1002 i'm talking about the time when big
mom hits luffy with a lightning attack
but that doesn't affect him because he's
made of rubber that of course makes
sense but then right after that kaido
hits luffy with a blast breath and kaido
is shocked to see that his flame attack
doesn't seem to work on luffy either
this part was never fully explained
because the story just continued on with
the big fight and then once luffy
awakened his devil fruit everything
really kicked into high gear luffy's
devil fruit awakening also known as gear
5 has been called the most ridiculous
power in the world and it essentially
allows its user to become a looty tunes
character luffy's hair and clothes
suddenly turn white his heartbeat
transforms into the drums of liberation
and he begins laughing as his entire
being is filled with joy he now has the
freedom to fight in whichever way he
sees fit he can do everything from
turning into a giant and changing his
shape like a cartoon character to using
his opponent's body as a jump rope and
taking control of lightning by giving it
the properties of rubber this is truly
the definition of overpowered and it is
no wonder that the nika devil fruit
became synonymous with sun god nika the
nika devil fruit powers are straight up
godly and describing the power as
ridiculous is not even an exaggeration
in fact some believe that there is
practically no limit to the nika devil
fruit's power and that its user is only
limited by his own imagination it seems
clear that the original joy boy from 800
years ago was himself a user of the nika
devil fruit and apparently
the fruit had not awakened to its true
power ever since the time of joy boy
luffy is the first person to awaken it
in 8 full centuries and until it awakens
the nika fruit only gives its user the
properties of rubber which is why it was
referred to as the gomu gomunomi by the
world government they did not want
anyone to associate this fruit with joy
boy or sun god nika and since the fruit
hadn't awakened in so long they just
passed it off as a completely different
and much less powerful fruit that said
the world government did attempt to
retrieve the nika fruit on multiple
occasions but they failed every single
time
leading the gorosei to conclude that the
nika devil fruit has a will of its own
and that it is actively avoiding capture
by the world government now the real
question is this how did the nika fruit
become so insanely strong and
overpowered compared to the vast
majority of other devil fruits so much
so that its power is known as the most
ridiculous power in history there are
some interesting theories on this
subject including the theory that nika
is one of the several extremely rare god
type devil fruits as this theory goes
there are a handful of devil fruits out
there which stand above all others in
terms of both rarity and power and nika
is one of them nika is associated with
the sun god and back in skypia we saw
that the people there worshiped the god
of the sun the god of the rain the god
of the forest and the god of the earth
this has led to speculation that nika
could be one of four or even more god
type devil fruits and so this is the
true origin of nika's awesome power this
theory has been referenced by a lot of
people including multiple youtubers i
recall seeing 333 while talking about it
and then abd after him and i'm sure that
many others have discussed it as well
according to this theory dragon may
already have the rain god devil fruit
which allows him to control the weather
green bull might have the forest god
devil fruit which allows him to become a
forest and imusama may possess the earth
god devil fruit which is why eem was
shown spending time in a garden there is
also the possibility that blackbeard's
devil fruit the yamiyami nomi is a fifth
godly devil fruit whose true nature is
yet to be revealed although this is a
compelling theory green bull's recent
performance in wano drove a bit of a
wrench into the theory that he has an
incredibly overpowered godly devil fruit
and as i was reading through some of
your comments on my previous one piece
videos which is something that i do
often because a lot of your comments are
absolute fire and they even end up
inspiring future videos that i make i
came across this extremely interesting
comment from a user called i'm a towel
and yeah if you're wondering what tau li
from south park is doing now he's
theorizing about one piece apparently
anyway my boy towley asks a fascinating
question since blackbeard was somehow
able to consume two different devil
fruits and is now able to use both of
their unique powers at the same time
does this mean that these two devil
fruits are now connected forever when
blackbeard eventually dies
will the yami yaminomi and the guragura
no me be reincarnated as two separate
fruits or does the fact that they were
connected within a single person mean
that they will now be reincarnated as a
single devil fruit that possesses the
properties of both when i first read
this comment i thought it was a really
interesting question and then i moved on
but the more i thought about it the more
i kept coming back to luffy's devil
fruit and its ability to merge so many
different properties within a single
fruit since blackbeard was able to
consume two devil fruits at once it's
possible that someone else was able to
do the same at some point in the past so
what if the hitohito no me model nika
actually started out as multiple
completely different devil fruits but
they all eventually merged into one
single overpowered devil fruit after
they were consumed by a single person
the legendary joy boy after joy boy died
these different devil fruits
reincarnated as a single devil fruit the
godly fruit that we know today as nika
and so the rubber aspect of luffy's
power may have come from one devil fruit
the fire aspect may have come from a
different devil fruit the ability to
change the color of his hair and to
wildly change the size of his body may
come from yet another devil fruit whose
original powers may have involved some
form of shape-shifting and so on all
these different devil fruits may not
have been super rare on their own but
once all these powers were combined
inside a single person the original joy
boy they created the godly devil fruit
nika that was eventually passed down to
luffy this means that luffy may have
already consumed multiple devil fruits
without even realizing it because the
hitohito no me model nica is already a
fusion of several distinct devil fruits
that came together in order to create
the most ridiculous power in the world
the so-called god type devil fruits do
exist but they didn't appear by chance
instead they were deliberately created
by those who are able to consume the
power of more than one devil fruit at
the same time just like we saw
blackbeard do in the modern era after
these individuals died the god-type
devil fruits were born this means that
there could be more god type devil
fruits out there that we are yet to
encounter and it also means that
blackbeard has just created another one
himself by merging the yamiyami nomi and
the guragura nomi he may also consume
yet more devil fruits in the future
which could make the power of his godly
devil fruit even more ridiculous than
the nika devil fruit so what do you guys
think when a person is able to consume
two or more devil fruits at once like
blackbeard was somehow able to do do
these fruits eventually reincarnate as a
single overpowered devil fruit
furthermore could this very process
explain the unique properties of the
nika fruit and why it seems to include
such vastly different powers and
properties within a single devil fruit
finally is blackbeard currently in the
process of creating another godly devil
fruit one that could rival even nika
itself are we about to witness the final
showdown between two godly devil fruit
users luffy and blackbeard the two most
ridiculous powers in the world coming
together for the ultimate battle to the
death a battle that will rock the entire
world of one piece don't forget to leave
your thoughts down in the comments below
and yes i clearly do read your comments
because they sometimes inspire entire
videos like this one if you guys enjoyed
this video and you want to see more in
the future leave a quick like it only
takes you a second but it helps me out a
lot and if you haven't already don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications it is a completely free
but very important way of directly
supporting the channel you can also hit
me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror thanks again to bloodline
heroes of lithus for sponsoring this
video check them out right now link in
the description as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys